My ferritin is 37, and total iron is 107 in a blood test on February this year.
You told me that my foot cramps may be from low iron.
Do I have to take any kind of iron if yes, which one?
I wouldn't give you, I'm just saying, I answered a question based upon what could cause cramping.
So low minerals, low iron, those are the things that can be a cause of cramping.
But I wouldn't as a person with cancer, I wouldn't use iron unless I had other signs of anemia.
So I wouldn't recommend a cancer patient, use iron if they solely based upon their total iron
and their total ferritin.
Because honestly, your total iron of 107 is within normal range.
So optimal range of total iron is like 85 to 130, so it's like perfect.
Your ferritin is within normal range too.
So I wouldn't based upon those lab findings give you total, I wouldn't give you iron.
Your ferritin might be a little bit low based upon optimal range, but you're definitely in standard lab range with baritone.
And then the other thing a person with cancer has to be careful with iron is that cancer had gobbled up iron.
So we'd only give iron if the person showed signs of anemia, low hemoglobin, low hematocrit, low red blood cell count and low total iron.
So we would jump to that.
Yeah, I just, I wouldn't jump to that.